MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, the show
for startups on Google
Developers Live.
I'm Martin Omander and I'm
joined by Don Dodge, Googler
and longtime investor and
startup evangelist.
Today we're going to talk
about getting funded.
So Don, I hear a lot of startups
asking me, what
should a good pitch to
investors contain?
DON DODGE: Several things.
The first thing that investors
are interested in is the team,
the team that's going
to build it.
So they want to know about you,
where you came from, what
experience you have, and sort of
what domain experience you
have to make this company
successful.
So they want to know about you,
and they want to know
about your co-founders.
Co-founder is important.
Very, very, very, few companies
get funded with a
single founder, so they want to
know what is the team, you
and your co-founders.
Also, advisers.
So do you have advisers with
domain experience in this
industry who can give you good
advice, who have been
successful at this before and
are willing to help you?
So team and advisers
number one.
Product, number two.
So what is it you're building?
Who is the user?
Who is the customer?
How will they use it?
So some use cases about how a
customer or user will use your
product, what problem does it
solve, or what does it make it
easier to do.
The third thing is the
revenue model.
So you don't need to have
revenue and you don't need to
have all of the answers, but
you at least need to have
thought about, what are the
revenue models I could
employee here?
How would they work?
Who would pay?
How much would they pay?
How does that compare
to some competitors?
Which leads to the fourth
thing-- competition.
What does the market
look like?
How big is the market?
How big could it be?
Who are the competitors?
What are their weaknesses?
What are you doing better?
The fourth thing-- fifth thing--
is the milestones that
you'll achieve.
So you tell them, I need a
million dollars and it will
last me 12 to 18 months, and
in this time frame, I'll
accomplish these milestones.
And there should be two or
three milestones, interim
milestones, so that they can
measure the success.
So those are the basic
components of a pitch.
You can put other things in, but
those are the sort of five
things that investors
are interested in.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So team, including advisers,
product, including use cases,
revenue model, market and
competitors, demo, how much
money you're asking for,
and milestones--
DON DODGE: That's right.
MARTIN OMANDER: --could hit.
I think it's a good point,
especially around use cases.
I sometimes hear about we're
going to simplify X, and then
it's kind of hard to understand
what the startup's
really doing.
DON DODGE: Yes.
It's important for investors to
understand what is it that
you're doing, because they don't
live this every day.
So you're passionate about your
idea, but they don't live
this every day, so they don't
know what the use cases are or
what the problems might be
that you're solving.
So use cases help explain that
in a way that everyone can
understand.
MARTIN OMANDER: I think in the
book called "Made to Stick"
about presentations, they call
it the curse of knowledge.
You are the expert.
You know far more than the
others in the room and that
means that you think they know
as much and then you don't
tell them enough.
DON DODGE: Or that they
care as much.
And they don't.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes.
DON DODGE: Passion is important
in a pitch.
It's more than words on paper.
It's investors are looking in
your eye and seeing if you
have passion about this idea--
not only that you understand
it and that you have
experience, but do
you have passion
about making this happen.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
DON DODGE: Important
component.
MARTIN OMANDER: Because then
even if your first idea
doesn't completely work out,
you can reuse some of what
you've done and pivot a little
bit and keep going with the
same team and same passion
and do something similar.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
That's why investors say they
invest in teams, because they
know that the idea will pivot
and change slightly as you go
along and learn more.
But it's important that the team
be strong and passionate
and listen to ideas
and advice.
MARTIN OMANDER: And maybe it's
easier to judge passion then
to judge particular
ideas as well.
DON DODGE: It is for
investors, yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: For
investors, right.
OK, so I hear a lot of startup
founders from very early
startups saying that, I need to
polish it a little better,
my product.
I don't want to release it,
get in the hands of users,
give them a poor experience.
I want it to be just right
before I release it.
When should a startup get
off their butts and get
their app out there?
DON DODGE: As soon
as possible.
Remember, software
is never done.
You're always improving
software.
So Google is 14 years old,
and we're improving the
software every day.
So don't think that you need
to continuously polish it
before you give it to
users or customers.
You've heard the MVP--
minimum viable product.
What that means is as soon as
you have something that's
demonstrable of the idea--
it doesn't have to have all
the bells and whistles and
work-- but get it into the hands
of some beta customers,
some beta users, so that
you can get feedback.
That feedback will guide your
priorities and how you develop
the product going forward.
It's never done, and you might
never be totally satisfied
with it, but get it out there
and start getting feedback.
It's OK that your first 50 users
or 100 users don't get
the optimal experience.
You're going to have thousands
or tens of thousands of users,
so learn from those initial
users, get the feedback as
quickly as you can.
MARTIN OMANDER: Launch
early, launch often.
Is that it?
DON DODGE: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Very good.
Thank you, Don.
That's all for today.
Please leave your comments and
questions under this YouTube
video, and we'll get back to
them in future episodes.
Thanks for joining us
and see you at the
same time next week.
Bye.